what is your name Kamala Khan I was just  some weird kid from Jersey who didn't  fit in I kind of stole something off of  Ames server huh what why why Amy cost  people like me and human claims were  sick violet  it's a disease what cement well I don't  believe it what if the Avengers were set  up  aim the so-called cure it's not lining  up that there's something wrong and I  can feel it don't you  the kid isn't human we did this and she  needs your help I can't I can't you  can't what you're ditching me hey don't  take it personally kid no this is what  he does  this was a mistake  so you're both just gonna walk away The  Avengers were set up cap was murdered  think I don't know that I've replayed  that day in my head a thousand times  Tessa but no one cares the world needed  someone to blame and he gave them their  scapegoat  so unless you have some kind of  astounding proof I suggest you both get  off my land what is that  proof  [Applause]